what up space fam goes in here from
anime outboard and i'm back at it again
to discuss the latest one piece chapter
where we got to see some crazy stuff so
make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy seeing these one-piece
chapter reviews and want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
channel the pirate king within
and smash that like button until it's
blue if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
actually know when a new video comes out
and while you wait a week for the next
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing playlist where you'll find
videos about the yonko warlord supernova
and much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all
first i want to comment on the cover of
this week's sean and jump
love seeing the supernova on the front
truly an
epic alliance i love all these guys
we're told that the strong stand side by
side striking a defiant pose
with their sights set for the very top i
love to see it and i love how inspiring
it is to read that their sights are set
for the very top
luffy ain't taking no second place it's
pirate king or die
trying and you gotta respect that
resolve we're also told that the battle
against
the beast pirates is nearing its climax
a huge statement
this whole arc is set up to be so
climactic
and i just know i'll freak out when we
get the climax of this
very climactic arc we also see an
awesome cover spread of kaido the
all-stars and the flying six
i'm obviously hoping these guys will
lose but it's still
super cool to see them set up in such a
cool fashion in one big color spread
you see king taking up the center
suggesting his own important role in the
crew
and probably in the ark as well anyways
this chapter
is called the honorable hyogoro
the flower a title that suggests we may
see this flower of ayakuza boss
bloom once more before he goes out we
have one of kaido's lookouts figure out
quickly that
momo is inside yamato's clothing hanging
onto her back
it's funny even though he's just a kid
he's called the leader of wano samurai
army
and then we see his very satisfied face
as he's holding on to yamato's bare body
definitely can't blame him for that
sanji overhears a nearby transmission
that they're chasing after momo and
shinobu and he wonders who is young
master yamato we all know interactions
between yamato
and sanji are going to be hilarious the
issue is though
that now sanji is not sure where he'll
be of more help
kinemon and mom are in opposite
directions and now we're not sure where
he'll choose to go
will we get to see him in love with
yamato or fighting jack
as i was hoping we would let me know
what you think but if he ends up going
after momo
oda definitely trolled us with that
matchup earlier the thing is
since that mysterious figure with the
scabbards might take on jack
we may well see sanji go after momo but
we can't be 100
sure either way and as usual oda leaves
us with another cliffhanger he's so good
at making us
desperate to see the next chapter by
giving us so many things to wonder about
after the chapter is done
we see onigashima floating reminding us
that time is ticking and adding more
urgency to the crazy battle it would be
a huge tragedy and loss if kaido
succeeds in crushing the old capital
with his floating island we also finally
catch up to pero sparrow and as i
predicted
carrot and wanda couldn't really do
anything to him
even in their sioux long forms and now
that the weather isn't in their favor as
pero sparrow says
with the moon being covered they really
stand no chance and got
wrecked it's noteworthy that pero
sparrow
does say it was a close call but the
fact is he seems completely fine
while the other two look like they're on
the floor dying again nothing too
surprising here
the more interesting thing is how
perispero spares her and remember he
wasn't
arguably too much to blame for pedro
either
so it's interesting finding out about
what kind of guy this antagonist is
he was down to team up with marco he's
obviously punishing carrick for
trespassing in their territory because
he's a pirate
but he doesn't mercilessly kill her
which would obviously be the smart thing
to do
if their fight was actually a close call
as he said he even warns her that if she
doesn't want to mourn
any more of her friends she should hop
back to the woods and chew on some grass
of course he seems like a huge jerk and
i'm sure we all hate seeing anyone hurt
the incredibly cute karachon
but honestly you can expect a pirate to
do much worse than perospero did here
especially to someone who wants revenge
against them at the end of the day
i find what he didn't do more
interesting than what he did do
he's going to be fascinating to watch in
this arc he strolls off and says he's
still against allying with the beast
pirates
but we must teach these upstarts what it
means to be an emperor
again nothing personal there just
carrying out pirate business
and he still emphasizes that he's
against allying with the beast pirates
even after everything big mom said to
him could he
actually help marco after all all i know
is that my
eyes are gonna be glued to peril sparrow
during this arc
and i can't wait to see what he ends up
doing we jump to chopper working on the
cure while everyone struggles to
preserve themselves the flames from
marco help while people have stamina but
people are fast approaching their limit
and they'll quickly
regress to ice demons if something
doesn't change quick
another sense of urgency being thrown
into this conflict for good measure
if this happens the ice demons will
rampage and eventually die from
exhaustion
but not before spreading the ice demon
illness to more people
up who is still standing as subordinates
look to him for guidance
they wonder why queen would expose them
to this while puss has quit your
whimpering
since queen won't be moved by it
although i'm not a huge fan of apu
never was you gotta give him his props
here he's still on his feet and he's
calm cool and collected at the same time
refusing to whine because it won't do
him any good and he knows it
the wall keeping them from chopper is
made up of a canadian rapper and a
yakuza flower
if drake were to switch sides again that
would be truly terrible for us
but he's been reliable so far and
hyogoro is back to his prime judging
from outward appearances
they straight up say that the yakuza
boss is too strong and they can't get
close to chopper who they hilariously
keep calling a tanuki
or japanese raccoon dog so how did
hyogoro
go from being a shriveled up old geezer
to his prime physique
well he explains that being exposed to
the ice demon virus
may have brought him close to death but
it also seems to have drawn out his
dormant strength
it's one of those classic shonen
situations where at the cost of
exchanging your remaining
life force you can gain exceptional
power for a period of time
and hyogoro decides to use this power to
cut down the enemy's main forces
while bravely fighting off the ice demon
virus as best as he can
unfortunately though the ice is
spreading fast
i really like the fact that the
so-called flower got to bloom one more
time
and go out in such a powerful way at the
peak of his glory it reminds me of rock
lee saying the lotus of the hidden leaf
village blooms twice
and i love how oda handled this flower
as well
and hyogoro is just such an honorable
guy
that you can't help but respect him he
eventually tells his men that they're
gonna need to end his life without
hesitation
so he doesn't end up indiscriminately
killing everyone in the hall
before he has to go though hyogoro uses
one sword flower style against the enemy
forces
they comment that that style is obsolete
and yet
they get absolutely wrecked and you love
to see it and i definitely love this
moment
not only because kyogre got to shine the
attack
is even called holy light but also
because he
showed them that the old style is far
from obsolete
people like to be trendy and up to date
on the new styles but with martial arts
as with most things
new doesn't always mean better for
example there were philosophy books
written
thousands of years ago that are straight
up better more applicable and more
effective
than many books being written today a
master is a master at the end of the day
and hyogoro is a master he used to
wonder about
what could have been if he in his prime
teamed up with odin
to beat kaido back in the day but he
doesn't anymore because he trusts
in the next generation to carry on the
fight he trusts in kinemon
and his interesting new protege meaning
our boy luffy himself
he smiles knowing the sun will rise on a
better future
for wano even if he doesn't live to see
it
characters like this who live for others
and face death in such a brave and noble
way are the ones i respect the most
and hyogoro has definitely earned
respect queen sees shoguro and attempts
to stop him worried that he'll take out
the whole floor by himself if he isn't
stopped another huge compliment to
hyogoro and just when he's about to fire
off a shot
marco comes in with the save rather than
sticking to one yanko commander why not
throw in another one
he tells queen that if he wants the
samurai
he has to kill marco first another
epically cool
character in action marco has been so
good in this arc
and in this chapter he solidifies his
legendary status
the dude is fighting kaido's strongest
commanders
at the same time and even shocks king
with his blue bird attack and then knees
him into the building with
super speed and super strength then he
kicks queen away
sending him flying off like team rocket
into another building
with his phoenix claw attack and then
our phoenix dude comments that chopper
should hurry up because as expected
holding back two foes with bounties over
a billion
isn't easy and as he said it clearly
isn't easy
for him and it's clear that he can't
keep it up forever but that doesn't take
away from how amazing marco was in this
chapter he was absolutely incredible
although hyogoro's arc is more emotional
right now
i still gotta give marco mvp for this
chapter
the dude never ceases to amaze me and is
practically
keeping everyone alive with his flames
as he kicks around two yonko commanders
as far as i know we haven't gotten a
specific bounty number for king
but queens is a whopping 1.32 billion
and most of us assume that kings is even
higher
and although we don't get a specific
number marco has kindly confirmed for us
that it's over a billion
interestingly enough pero sparrow
notices this insane fight
and comments that marco looks pretty
worn out again
what will pero sparrow do now that he's
here would he really join the guys he
doesn't want to be allies with to beat
marco
or will he follow his own initial plan
and help marco out
can't wait to see logically from a
machiavellian standpoint
marco is obviously not as big of a
threat as the beast pirates as a whole
so it would be better in theory to take
this chance to get rid of a more
formidable threat at the very least that
would be the right way to play risk
as people are turning back into ice
demons his men prepare to kill hyogoro
does kyogro show fear or pity himself
absolutely not
this legend calmly awaits his death as
he thanks the heavens for these last few
moments
where he got to bloom once more and
helped the cause
his men cried just like socrates's
friends cried
as he calmly prepared for death and like
socrates hyogoro doesn't cry
he just lets us know that he's leaving
the rest to the others
and he says that he no longer has any
regrets
he can die completely at peace with his
life and we're told
with that he entrusts his hopes and
desires to his comrades
goosebump inducing moment right here and
not just because he looks extremely cold
i don't know if hyogoro will actually
die here but
it would be a fitting end for him no
doubt
the only thing is the fact that oda
didn't kill him
in this chapter which suggests to me
that he might not actually die right
away but hey there's oda at it again
giving us more reasons and questions
that make us desperate for the next
chapter to come out as soon
as possible like kyogro oda is clearly a
master at his craft
but that is it for this chapter which
was most definitely an epic one
as usual let me know how you like this
chapter and what you're expecting to see
happen in the next one let me know who
your mvp for this chapter was
drop that in the comments if you do
enjoy seeing these one-piece chapter
reviews i want to keep them coming the
best
you can do is channel the pirate king
within and smash that like button until
it's blue
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you
actually know when a new video drops and
while you wait a week for the next
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing
one piece playlist where you'll find
videos about the yonko warlord supernova
and much more link to that is in the
description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank
the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grotto the world acquire respect but
they have a liam thompson al-jatal
dr cortman johnny boy draws emperor
otaku
spidey life to now baked buddhist and
tungsten tarkis and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers
angel cruz anatoly kozlowski joe stanton
very gucci jessica kayla fond
rethuen de ora alicia actor bonnie parks
hinokami and water the red haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted no ted deadly saint matthew
cruz and anthony schreiber thank you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing epic people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life waifus and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
animeoper link to that is in the
description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button
that you've hopefully already clicked so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer
whichever way you support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you